I'm gonna have an acai Bowl it's acai
okay okay
hi I'm Bruno marchesini and today I'm
gonna be talking about some of my
favorite snacks
[Music]
I was so excited for this one okay
thank you
so this is pasakita this is sweet but
also a bit salty because it's peanuts
it's like peanut butter but more solid
you're gonna see the texture right now
it's
[Music]
so good
in the middle of the Year June July
August we have this party it's called
genina it is a theme party and we eat a
lot of this during this time of the year
my mom makes this great kanjika it's
another Brazilian dish and I put this on
top of it
my Unified
fake going back to Brazil with me
okay
love this one this is like world famous
you guys should know this this is sponge
occasion cheese bread
it's made of tapioca you guys are
familiar with tapioca right so it's
cheese and tapioca flour and it's just
really great it feels about it's salty
um
it's so good
it's a minute a second Brazil know it's
good
sorry versus Superior
at least food wise
I like to have it for like breakfast but
it's also like a great snack and every
single friend I have when they go to
Brazil they become obsessed with this
and you can't eat just one
you know you have to eat like 30.
next up is
brings back some memories this reminds
me of my childhood it's a cookie this
one is with chocolate there's a
strawberry version
I don't remember the last time I had it
hmm yeah I used to have it like all the
time when I was a kid but there's always
some pasta temple on set when I'm
shooting Brazil my Blue Beetle co-star
sholo mariduenia he's the foodie just as
I am so that's basically all we do we go
out or eat and cholo
went to Brazil and he's obsessed with
the food
as you should be so I'm taking some of
this for him okay okay
I really am you're gonna be mad at me if
I don't
no way
and it's acai not acai guys acai I'm
gonna have an acai Bowl it's acai okay
okay
oh yes some people yeah they have it
with it
[Music]
yeah but I'd rather eat it with a spoon
and this is lechinino how do you guys
say it father of milk in Brazil you can
have it with whatever you want granola
fruits I like to have it with this I
used to think it was I don't know it
looks kind of disgusting
really good
[Music]
hi this is the best
interview ever
this one is guarana this one is also
really famous it's a soda made of this
fruit right here small tiny red fruit
super sweet super good
you can have it with anything
cheers this is great this is amazing I
love this my mom wouldn't let me have a
lot of this as a kid because it's soda
and also it's made of guarana so it
gives you a lot of energy this one I
have to take one for show though
otherwise he's gonna be so freaking mad
at me unfortunes phrase or piece of
slang specific to Brazil that you think
everyone should know so there's this one
I can only think of the bad ones right
now there's this one that is like
I'm saying this
you're gonna have to bleep the cool word
which means
so to follow the from your butt
it's like when you're real
sorry but it's like when you're
something that it's really surprising or
it's too much you say Edge
sorry
[Music]
bye
okay this is the last one yes huh
oh this is guava cheese it's just guava
and cheese
but in Brazil we call it Julieta Romeo
and Juliet we love it so much that we do
eye screams we use it as a filling for
like pastel pastels like empanadas we do
everything with this this is something
you would have After High School with
your family your friends
um barbecue a Brazilian trash is a bit
different than you we don't do hot dogs
we just do meat yeah
[Music]
oh
I miss home already I just got here
what a great day
thank you guys for watching me I'm
having the time of my life and talking
about my favorite sex and don't forget
to watch Blue Beetle out on August 18th
[Music]